ja der protest der blieb aber nicht nur
vor dem brandenburger tor und damit in
hör- und sichtweite zum
reichstagsgebäude nein der protest kam
auch bei den politikern im
reichstagsgebäude an und war dort zu
spüren
wirtschaftsminister peter altmaier wurde
dort bedrängt und gefilmt die bilder
mit der einfach nicht sagen oder klar
vertreten waren nachher gar nicht
übernehmen und bei den wählern nicht nur
die kleinen haben
diese gehören daher sind sie besonders
gerne der größten not even erreicht
haben und freuen uns diesen künftig
deutlich nach oben
wir haben überhaupt kein gewissen setzt
man die pleite gerissen
[Musik]
so könnte
aufgeblasen mit kleiner wannabe könig
was uns über dieses video nochmal
sprechen wer war das wer ist da
reingekommen in den bundestag ins
reichstagsgebäude und hat da so das
handy filmt ins gesicht vom
wirtschaftsminister gehalten
ja mir ist noch nicht bekannt wer genau
das war und wer diese person in den
bundestag gebracht hat es ist allerdings
bekannt dass dieser vorfall bei der
bundespolizei auch gemeldet wurde
wenn man sich mal anhört was die person
sagt und wie sie es sagt die
konfrontativ sie vorgeht dann erinnert
sie ehrlich gesagt an abgeordnete der
afd
das wird aus diesen kreisen natürlich
auch bejubelt
die frage ist natürlich warum wie kann
es sein dass an einem solchen tag
überhaupt menschen in den bundestag
kommen dazu muss man sagen ist es gut
dass menschen in den bundestag kommt
dass bürger in den bundestag kommt der
bundestag hat auch selbst versucht sich
vor solchen sachen zu schützen
an einem normalen tag ist es so dass ein
bundestagsabgeordneter mehrere personen
in das bundestagsgebäude bringen kann
ohne sie anzumelden
das heißt dass niemand ist bekannt wer
diese person sie sind sind sie müssen
nicht durch einen sicherheitscheck diese
regel wurde für heute aufgehoben das
heißt heute also diese frau die wir
sehen hier wurde heute auch angemeldet
das heißt es lässt sich auch
herausfinden wer sie angemeldet hat
insgesamt muss man natürlich sagen dass
und unwürdige bilder für das parlament
allerdings keine unwürdigen bilder für
peter altmaier der sich da wirklich
hervorragend verhalten hat sich so
verhalten wie ein minister sich zu
verhalten hat wenn eine eine bürgerin
die unhöflich ist die rabiates die grob
ist die unanständig ist im konfrontiert
er hat höflich geantwortet und ist
seiner wege gegangen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren